le casting des avengers est énorme
surtout par rapport à endgame et après
dix longues années
ils sont et amassé des héros et des
personnages récurrents plus ou moins
importants dans la saga mais c'est ça à
moitié le problème avec plus d'une
trentaine de héros dans la série les
gloires les moments de mise en valeur
d'importance bah c'est pas du tout
équitable entre tous le monde
aujourd'hui tony est mort steve après sa
retraite black widow nous a également
quitté bref l'ère des premiers avengers
est entre guillemets terminer ce qui va
laisser concrètement de la place aux
autres et aux nouveaux néanmoins
notamment par le biais de la phase 4
beaucoup de héros vont rejoindre le cast
qui va encore s'agrandir
sauf qu'il y a des héros qui sont là et
qui seront encore là pour la suite et
qui pour moi méritent plus que la valeur
qu'on leur a donné durant ces dix
dernières années
bref voilà n'oubliez pas le petit pouce
bleus et la cloche car nous allons voir
ensemble pour moi cinq personnages qui
mérite mieux dans le futur de la saga
ps c'est une vidéo totalement subjective
donc je vous invite vous à partager en
commentaire les personnages qui
mériterait mieux d'après votre avis
personnel si je vous parle de hulk en
premier ce n'est pas pour rien le
personnage a été pour moi grandement
ignoré et réduit dans la saga surtout
les derniers films
le problème étant que banner est le
héros qui a le moins de chances d'avoir
un avenir glorieux dans la phase iv où
le futur du mc eu ce dernier faisait
partie des tous premiers avengers
les six originaux et contrairement à
d'autres personnages base ce dernier a
eu droit à plus de 10 années de
développement et alors que nous nous
attendions à le voir exploser dans
infinity ward ou endgame le héros a subi
le choix scénaristiques de ne pas
réussir à se transformer dans le premier
volet du prologue de la saga marvel ce
qui a clairement grandement réduit son
importance et dans ngame bas banner est
devenu professeur hulk sans explication
claire et son utilisation s'est réduite
avant tout à faire le claquement de
doigts inversée acte qui nous a une fois
de plus prouvé sa puissance due aux
rayons gamma
mais surtout le goût amer que ce dernier
aurait pu faire de grandes choses si la
ville
mieux considéré à l'heure actuelle
scénaristiquement banner a perdu natacha
a perdu ses amis d'origine
bref il est seul et concernant ses
aptitudes il a toujours eu besoin de
tony pour brouiller qui est
malheureusement parti
hulk méritait mieux et est
malheureusement l'avenir pour lui n'ira
pas en s'améliorant
la seule porte de sortie pour moi serait
de le voir dans la future histoire de
schild qui reprendra probablement le
flambeau et qui sait il est possible que
marvel décide un jour de lui dédier un
film pour combler les trous
scénaristiques comme celui de black
widow
malheureusement le personnage restera
menotté tant qu universal sera dans les
parages
je vous la vous au départ j'avais plus
d'espoir que l'avenir du personnage de
spider man soit celui nous montrons la
plus grande courbe d'importance du futur
du mc eu mais au vu des freins de
l'alliance sony et marvel
il est clair que ce sera au rwanda c'est
comme si le personnage depuis tout ce
temps avait été menotté caché menti mais
il va être temps que ça change
luanda est un personnage très secondaire
dans les avengers et elle a commencé
tout doucement à prendre du galon depuis
ultra rwanda était au départ une cobayes
d'idra qui y fit des expériences sur la
jeune fille via le centre de loki qui
contenait la pierre de l'esprit c'est
comme ça que wendat a obtenu ses super
pouvoirs
néanmoins tout comme bruce elle a
largement été réduite par rapport aux
choix de scénaristique
néanmoins à l'heure actuelle cette
dernière va avoir sa propre série ou
honda vision où elle mènera une vie avec
son acolyte de toujours
une série qui apparemment aurait une
importance capitale pour le futur du mc
hugh et série qui permettra d'introduire
le second film du docteur strange en
compagnie de la jeune protagoniste
on l'a vu dans endgame rwanda et
surpuissantes et sa puissance semble
enfin véritablement se révéler capable
mais encore inconsciente de sa starlette
which peut manipuler les réalités et les
déformer une thématique qui entre
parfaitement dans celles qui aimeraient
instauré les scénaristes des prochains
films marvel
et nous en reparlerons prochainement
mais les intrigues de la série one la
vision nous montrerons ces manipulations
puisque rwanda et vision semble se
trouver dans les années 50 ou 80 avec la
tenue officielle etc bref ils vont
changer de temporalité mais nous en
reparlerons bientôt rwanda n'a besoin
que du soutien de vision son amour
éternel et d'une aide extérieure pour
l'aider à comprendre et manipuler son
pouvoir et je suis certain que strange y
sera pour quelque chose
si cette dernière possède une place
principale dans le film du docteur ce
n'est pas pour rien luanda va passer à
la catégorie supérieure
et il était vraiment temps antoine est
pour moi possiblement le héros le plus
sous côtés
dois-je rappeler qu'il est à l'origine
de la solution d'avengers endgame et que
c'est grâce au chant quantique que les
avengers ont pu voyager à travers le
temps scott langues
un atout majeur quant à l'avenir du mc
eu plus le temps avance et plus ce
dernier maîtrise les voyages dans le
champ quantique une thématique qui comme
pour rwanda rentre parfaitement dans les
objectifs de l'avenir du mc hugh le
champ quantique apporte nouvelle
dimension nouvelle temporalité mais
également j'aimerais souligner que
thanos a réduit les pierre d'infini à
l'état d' d'atomes donc actuellement
parmi tous les héros seul antoine est
capable de tenter quelque chose pour
potentiellement les récupérer ce n'est
pas anodin du tout maintenant de nouveau
en compagnie de hank pym sa femme et la
guêpe
les quatre protagonistes vont pouvoir
reprendre leurs expériences et faire de
grandes choses dans le troisième opus du
héros comme découvrir le micro verse par
exemple ou réveiller chronos et c'est
quand je pense à blake panthères je me
dis que punaise il y à vraiment de
grandes choses à faire dans le mc eu
effectivement xala a une particularité
par rapport aux avengers qui le rend
encore plus grand et j'espère de tout
coeur que c'est un point qui sera
développé dans son second film xala est
un roi le roi du wakanda soit le
dirigeant d'un pays africain avec un
peuple et c'est une thématique
réellement pertinente black panthères de
par son statut et son histoire est aussi
sage que steve rogers c'est d'ailleurs
pourquoi les deux héros
semblent s'apprécier autant et se
respecte de plus l'aspect politique est
quelque chose de peu exploité dans le mc
eu le seul moment nous avons eu droit à
une intrigue liée à ceux ci étaient
pendant civil war et cela a totalement
divisé les héros xala lui a le
background et les moyens de se quereller
avec les plus grands politiciens du
monde comme notamment thunderbolt ojos
d'ailleurs à la fin de son film dédié
black panthères souhaite s'ouvrir au
monde et se développer sur la planète
donc arrêté l'isolationnisme soin de se
fermer aux autres et de fonctionner tout
seul puis à force d'être un dirigeant
aimé de son peuple
xala a la carrure pour justement réunir
et guider les avengers lors de leurs
péripéties contre leurs futurs ennemis
nous devons voir plus de blagues
panthères
non s'il vous plaît restez vous ne rêvez
pas et s'il vous plaît ne me jugez pas
je vais vous expliquer je suis ultra
navré que le personnage de carol denver
ce divise autant les foules
il est clair que marvel à un désir avéré
de promouvoir un message féministe
derrière cette héroïne
ce qui est bien mais le personnage ne
s'arrête pas là si je désigne carole
comme sous côté ce n'est pas à cause de
ses pouvoirs a évidemment mais dues aux
futures intrigues scénaristique qu'elles
risquent d'amener suite à l'explosion
supraluminique carroll a obtenu des
pouvoirs venant tout droit de la gemme
de l'espace elle est comme une sorte de
mini pierre d'infini et c'est là que le
personnage est intéressant
sûre d'elle arrogante insolente parfois
hautaine carole n'est pas une héroïne
comme les autres elle est beaucoup trop
puissante mais genre vraiment et
contrairement aux autres personnages qui
deviennent plus forts et plus mesuré
petit à petit carole est déjà au sommet
de sa puissance est là où j'aimerais
vous faire réfléchir
et quant au futur de carole et notamment
captain marvel 2 cette dernière est au
milieu du conflit
cris contre scroll et en plus de ça elle
est accompagnée de nick fiori carole
n'est pas une divinité
elle reste une humaine qui a subi un
accident dont captain marvel bas elle ne
peut pas tout résoudre
et encore moins qu'avec la force il va
falloir qu'elle en prenne conscience car
les sous coté car elle va nous montrer
quelque chose de neuf dans le mca
elle va nous montrer des faiblesses
mentales des potentiels trahison des
scroll ou rébellion des cris voire même
un deuil celui de son ami de toujours
carroll a roulé sur son premier film
elle se fera rouler dessus dans le
deuxième
et là le personnage devra se remettre en
question et atteindre une plus grande
sagesse et ouverture d'esprit
je suis certain que fiori il sera pour
quelque chose il est après tout la seule
personne qu'elle écoute nous arrivons
maintenant à la fin de la vidéo je vous
invite vous de votre côté à me partager
dans les commentaires les héros qui pour
vous mériterez mieux
ou que vous trouvez tout simplement sous
côté je vous rappelle encore une fois
que cette vidéo est totalement
subjective et n'engage que ma vision
personnelle
si la vidéo vous a plu et que vous en
souhaitez d'autres n'hésitez pas à me le
faire savoir en lâchant votre plus beau
pouces bleus en activant la cloche et en
vous abonnant cela me soutient
énormément
évidemment on va reparler de marvel très
vite je voulais m'essayer à ce nouvel
exercice un petit peu et c'était rigolo
à faire je lave ou bon allez bref
c'était argot rock et que le live earth
soit avec vous djaout
[Musique]
les fans n'ont quà main